what's interesting neil cavuto earlier
this week decided to issue Donald Trump
a little warning take a listen to what
Neil Cavuto had to say to President
Trump but last time I checked you are
the president United States so tweeting
out these tacky insults well it just
seems beneath you and I think it is
going to cost you you're running out of
friends faster than you are running out
of time you might not like bob Corker
but a lot of senators do and you need
those senators sir even assuming some of
them have gotten used to this how long
do you think they put up with this
loyalty works both ways mr. president
and whether you think you're justified
or not punching down and exactly helping
you punch through
now I'm sure ripping the establishment
rates with your base but that doesn't
make your tone and conduct to me at
least any less space not only does it
demean a United States Senator I think
it demeans you I know some admire a
president who speaks his mind but some
of your tweets alone are making the
people you need run for cover
maybe you're frustrated by the process
maybe the bureaucracies got you swamp
interesting thing that Cavuto said
they're the people you need why does
Donald Trump need them great question
Donald Trump cannot continue to alienate
members of Congress and not just because
of the hole he needs them to pass
legislation thing again they're all on
the same page as far as legislation goes
Trump wants what the Republican Party
wants so he's not necessarily gonna need
to pull them to his side in order to get
things passed the reason and I feel like
Cavuto kind of skirted around this
because he didn't want to say it out
loud the reason Donald Trump running out
of friends is important the reason he
needs those people is because of the
25th amendment it's very easy in some
regards to remove a sitting president of
the United States if you have absolutely
no friends in Congress or if you
alienate your entire cabinet there are
some
different methods within the 25th
amendment that would allow for Donald
Trump to be removed from office without
ever having to go through the
impeachment process or ever having to
even fully conclude the Bob Muller
investigation a great example is that
there is one area of the 25th amendment
that says if 14 cabinet members come
together and say that the president is
unfit for office you're gone you get
removed from power temporarily you have
to then prove that you are fit and if
you are able to successfully prove that
you are fit you may retake office if you
do not prove it you're out same thing
goes with the Senate a certain number of
votes can do the same thing as long as
the vice president is along with it if
they vote that you were unfit or
incompetent or otherwise unable to
fulfill your duties as president in the
United States you're out of there so
what happens when Donald Trump gets on
Twitter and insults people like John
McCain or Murkowski or Collins or corker
or flake or any other number of people
that he's tried to alienate from his
life you think they're gonna stand by
his side if it ever comes down to 25th
amendment time do you think Mike Pence
is an itching to take over as president
of the United States we already know the
guy set up his own super PAC we know
he's been meeting with wealthy donors
over the last few months we know he's
cooking up little schemes down there so
it wouldn't surprise me if Mike Pence
had floated this idea perhaps maybe
maybe he's talked to them maybe he's
getting a feel for it but at the end of
the day Donald Trump cannot survive any
challenge to his presidency if he does
not have those Republicans on his side
and he doesn't understand that he
doesn't know it in fact a great story
was out this morning saying that Donald
Trump didn't even know what the 25th
amendment was and once it was explained
to him it had to be re explained to him
because he still didn't quite understand
what it meant he didn't know that it
could be used to remove him from power
he didn't know that it was really even a
thing he didn't know that he could be
removed from office without having to be
impeached but by that time maybe it was
too late when you start losing the Fox
News hosts we saw Rush Limbaugh come out
a Wednesday and say that Trump's
rhetoric is making him nervous by trying
to order the NFL to order their players
to stand that even Rush Limbaugh's
saying whoa whoa whoa probably not a
good thing to do you're making me
nervous when Neil Cavuto says please
stop alienating your friends when Ann
Coulter is ready to abandon you when
Alex Jones starts posing questions as to
your mental decline that's your base and
you will not continue to survive in
American politics if you don't have a
base I'm fair and Cousins sitting in for
David Pakman a day on the David Pakman
show
you can find me on Twitter at fair and
balanced you also find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire we'll
be right back with more David Pakman
show